la folie canoise basson plein alors
installez-vous bien confortablement car
nous allons vous faire découvrir le
festival comme si vous y étiez ici il y
a ceux qui viennent travailler faire du
business rencontrer des producteurs ou
des réalisateurs choisir les films qui
sert ensuite projetés dans leur salle ça
c'est pour la partie travail il y a ceux
aussi venus uniquement arpenter les
dance Flor de la
Croisette Luc boquan est directeur du
cinéet des lancours après 3 ans
d'absence il revient ici sur la
Croisette et la magie opère toujours ça
c'est rigolo ce que j'aime la CAN c'est
que c'est le grand CIR du cinéma enfin
c'est la fête du cinéma mondial tout le
monde est là la petite exploitation la
moyenne exploitation parce que moi je je
suis un exploitant mais il y a aussi des
producteurs distributeurs tout le monde
se mélange des comédiens des gens qu'on
connaît des gens qu'on rencontre donc
c'est l'occasion à la fois de voir des
films parce que nous on vient surtout
pour travailler pour voir des films pour
pouvoir les programmer les défendre les
suivre après dans nos salles et puis
aussi rencontrer des gens des
opportunités pour monter des projets
travailler ensemble et cetera voilà
c'est ça can puis c'est la fête du
cinéma mondial une fête à laquelle il
faut s'armer de patience pour aller voir
un film il est nécessaire parfois de s'y
prendre une à 2 heures avant la
projection avec en prime une longue file
d'attente faut savoir garder sa place Al
il y a aussi des fois des incivilités
tout à l'heure dans une file d'attente
des gens qui s'insultaient pour une
place de cinéma bon c'est quand même
c'est quand même voilà on vient voir des
films quoi on fait pas la guerre donc il
y a vraiment des fois des des des gens
qui s'énervent qui s'excitent qui sont
prêts à tout pour passer essayer de de
gruger passer devant quelqu'un et cetera
et cetera bon tu rentres pas tu rentres
pas c'est le jeu voilà on est à can on
va pas pleurer non plus c'est c'est un
moment super agrable dans une année
professionnel pour ceux qui travaillent
hein voilà bien sûr et dans les longues
files d'attente en compagnie des
collègues on partage idées et points de
vue sur les films on narrête pas on
discute de ce qu'on a vu parce qu'on
voit pas tous la même chose on discute
de ce qu'on essaie de voir parce qu'on
verra pas tous la même chos on discute
des différentes comment dirais-je
galères qu'on a et cetera et puis oui
oui on parle des films forcément voilà
c'est c'est normal un autre exploitant
éelinois a fait le déplacement à Cann
Gael Pinot responsable et programmateur
du cinéma Le Grenier à ATT trrappe lui
aussi enchaîne les projections toute la
journée et ce n'est pas toujours évident
d'avoir un avis sur un film alors c'est
très difficile de choisir puisqu'on voit
énormément de films on est c'est presque
on est presque gavé de film on les
enchaîne et ce que ce qu'on ressent sur
le moment c'est pas forcément c'est pas
forcément net parce qu'on les compare
les uns aux autres et c'est pas très
facile par contre c'est il faut les
digérer et avec le recul il y a il y a
beaucoup de choses qui reviennent et là
on peut vraiment réfléchir sur les films
et les aimer là si si tu me demandes le
film qui m'a le plus marqué c'est Mad
Max j'ai vraiment beaucoup aimé Mad
Max
survive pour une sal à r c'est pas
forcément le film que je vais le le plus
programmer
j'ai beaucoup aimé le wood j'ai beaucoup
aimé ce par rapport au précédent c'est
vraiment un film que j'ai apprécié je
programmer avec grand plaisir j'auris
très envie de montrer à mes
spectateursin comme se fix des objectifs
pendant le festival voir 4 à 5 films par
jour qu'il soit de la sélection
officielle ou dans les sélections
parallèles Un Certain Regard la Semaine
de la Critique la Quinzaine des
réalisateurs des invitations qu'il
décrochent grâce à une application pour
les exploitants on s'inscrit et là en
fait on a tous les films qu'on a demandé
alors quand ça s'affiche en rouge
évidemment ça veut dire qu'on a pas de
place et quand ça s'affiche en vert ça
veut dire qu'on a une place obtenue il
va y avoir quelques places de distribuer
en plus donc on on va essayer de les on
va essayer de les choper pour aller voir
le film à 11h30 chance pour nos
ivelinois il viennent de décrocher des
places pour aller voir le dernier film
de Gus
vinin mais il faut se dépêcher le film
commence dans 10 minutes can c'est la
fête du cinéma mais c'est également la
course